[Music]
sarah is with us in los angeles hi sarah
welcome to the ramsay show
well hello dave how are you better than
i deserve what's up
my husband and i are on baby step two
we've paid off 23 000
and have another 22 to go cool my mom
keeps asking me
to help her and my dad figure out their
budget
uh help them start on the ramsay plan i
just finished reading the total money
makeover and i gave her my copy
good um and now it's leading to us
fighting
my dad is 57 and my mom's 54 my dad
wants to retire soon
they keep trying to convince me that
their 800 credit score is good
my dad doesn't want to stop the 15 that
he's currently investing
um even though they're just shy of a
hundred and ten thousand dollars in debt
yeah well there's no reason to find
that's what i say do what i said that's
what i say
yeah well so i mean if they don't want
to do it they don't have to do it
well that's what i keep saying i'm not
going to fight over it
you guys do whatever you want to do you
ask me and so i
told you what we were doing i gave you a
copy of the book but you don't have to
do it it's not a law
well and that's what i'm trying to say
and then they turn around and they're
like oh well but we need to get out of
debt and we want to retire
yeah but i mean i showed you how you got
you got to decide which one you wanna do
you can't be
both
if you wanna know how i did it i showed
you how i did it i used the total money
makeover baby steps this is how i did it
i don't know how to tell you how to do
it other than that that's the only way i
know this is you talking okay
and so i'm and i'm not gonna fight with
you you guys can either do it or not do
it i'm gonna love you either way or my
mom and dad
i'm gonna love you even if you're stupid
don't say it don't say that but you can
think that
yeah right no they'll kill me i can't
say that i know i know but you see what
i'm saying
that's what's going through your head
right but here's the thing
the fight the fight comes when they
are trying to convince you to not do it
the ramsay stuff
the baby steps and the fight comes
when you are trying to convince them to
do the baby steps
so the best way you can convince them is
to continue to do it properly yourself
and win
and they'll con and it sets an example
for them but you can't make people do
stuff
yeah that's true you can make little
kids do stuff but you can't make grown
people do stuff
and you can only make your kids do stuff
kids do things you can only make little
kids do stuff until you leave the room
that's right sarah one of the things
sarah i hear the tension for you because
they keep asking you
and you're so passionate you're so
convicted on this journey
that you can't just answer a question
you know and i think that that's where
there may be some tension there and i
think dave's absolutely right
i think if they keep asking you a
question you go um i'm not sure i'll
text you later tonight
i think it's on page 87 of chapter three
or whatever and just stay out of the
communication if you're feeling
your tension rise because of your
tremendous conviction
then you're going to have to just when
they ask a question say i'll look it up
it's in this chapter it's in chapter
five
or it's in chapter six whatever it is
and give them the answer but don't get
involved in the back and forth opinion
stuff
because dave's right i don't want to do
that okay yeah great sure
that's cool i don't want i don't want to
stop putting money in my 401k
okay i mean i you know
i if somebody calls me up on the air
here
and i'm the guy okay it's not just like
a theory for me this is i'm the guy that
wrote it and did it for me and tens of
millions of people right
if somebody calls me up here on the air
and wants to argue with me i'll talk to
him for a minute or two
and then i just go to the next caller
i'm not going to have a debate with
somebody about this because i'm right
i'm not going to have a discussion about
it i mean i'm not right about everything
but this stuff i mean 20 million people
have done this stuff
under my direction so it's not like it's
wrong anymore
you know it's not it's not like an
opinion it's not a theory by a broke
college professor this is
this is we do this and this is i may not
be able to do anything else but this i
can do so i'm not going to argue with
you about it
if you don't agree with me you're just
what's known as wrong and america is a
great place you're allowed to be wrong
yeah and so you know you just have to be
kind about it and have a little bit of
that in your head a little bit of those
kinds of tapes almost sarcasm playing in
your head and you just kind of
don't be mean and don't be unkind and
just go dad
if you don't want to do that that's okay
i understand i love you
this is a plan i'm doing you are a grown
man you get to choose what you're going
to do
and i'm going to love you either way
yeah and that creates
the emotional boundary that you need you
need that
you need to be able to put a boundary
out there and go we're doing it we're
all in for us mom and dad
they got their big boy pants on and
they're big girl pants so at some point
uh don't get sucked into the back and
forth on it i'm not going to try to make
you do it and please don't try to make
me not do it
that's right there there's your clearest
boundary yeah and because
either one of those are going to cause a
problem and we're going to have it we're
going to have conflict and i don't want
to have conflict with you i just want to
love you
and there's no point in the conflict
because you're grown people you're
allowed to do
whatever you want to do even if you're
wrong i mean i got
i got relatives that vote wrong goal
heard
and and i love them anyway it's true
that's true it's okay they just don't
know how to vote and
you know no amount of talking to them
helps either no
so i just quit i quit arguing with them
a long time ago and i i just know my
vote got cancelled out by so-and-so
you know that's they just don't know how
to vote and so you just can't there's
something you just can't argue about
done doing good